I really want to start by saying
congratulations on the movie I thought
you did such a great job
thank you I appreciate that very much
pleasure to be here it's a very
interesting times all of these
connections now or vite there through
cyberspace at zoom or skype or facetime
it's crazy not to be there in person
yeah it's what I've been doing a lot of
its uh definitely bizarre so I before I
get started first I know you worked with
David Leitch a few times with you know
on atomic blonde the Deadpool and so he
said um I was told to ask you if you
remembers the first I mean I remember
the first time I worked with them I
don't know if he counts it but it went
for me it was Chad and Dave directing
second unit on reshoots for Street
Fighter that was the first time I recall
but then like the first time I think it
was the gaming responsibility was the
mechanic hired me is a fight in a fight
choreographer
he's the recollection may be different
but no I think he was probably trying to
have you talk about Street Fighter or
something you know yeah so definitely
before we get into extraction
I didn't want to jump backwards a little
bit and talk about how in the last few
years you've worked with Russo brothers
as second unit director and stunt
coordinator on Avengers I believe you
did Civil War and then infinity war and
an end game so I definitely want to
touch on what was it like working with
them and because those three films the
action everything about those movies
credible so if you could just talk a
little bit about working with them and
the experience of you know those films
yeah I actually first met the Russo
brothers in 2013 when we were shooting
Captain America the Winter Soldier
I was the stunt double for Captain
America and they were directing their
first big you know action movie for the
Marvel Universe and in that film I you
know I got on well with them and I
didn't have the kind of responsibility
that I would have later but I think we
made a connection and they saw kind of
my passion for filmmaking and love of
action and then they asked me to come
coordinate Captain America so
war and I on that movie I was doubling
and coordinating so I spent a lot of
time with them in the even the writing
room we were writing action sequences
and you know the script was there but we
wanted to delve deeper into these
characters and these sequences and we
spent a lot of time with things on the
page and then I would run off and do
what we they called a fight biz so we'd
shoot and cut the stunt team and I
shooting cut action sequences and design
fights and then take them back to the
Russos and they would go like you know I
think you know cap should do a little
more of this or they would have their
input and so we changed things and it
was actually through that process that I
learned a lot from them as a director
because I learned I worked with Chad I
worked with you know Dave and a lot of
and even Francis Lawrence use those
fight business to better their own movie
but for me I was doing that directing
practice I would you know do my version
of the scene take it to these really
great directors and get their feedback
and then I would be secretly and making
notes of how to make you know my future
movies better and so you know our my
relationship with Russo is developed and
then infinity war and the end game came
along and I I just can't say enough good
things about those do and how they they
pull you in and make you feel like
family and they were super supportive
and always looking out for you know
their friends and family and trying to
help and mentor and just be
collaborative filmmakers since you did
second unit on those three films what
might be something that fans would be
surprised to learn that you felt
well I I think the biggest
responsibility that was given was on in
the game and you might be surprised that
I filmed the kind of entirety of the cap
versus catfight I filmed the more and
more surprising was the the death scene
of nebula when you know there in the the
tunnel after Hawkeye has been fighting
all the creatures and there's a little
standoff there I filmed that entire
sequence so they gave me a lot of
responsibility on that movie because
there was so many things to be shot but
I also believed because it was infinity
war when they asked me to do extraction
and so when in get you know I went away
scouted on the in the interim between
those movies we shot him back-to-back
went away it's guided when I came back I
get a lot more responsibility and doing
a lot more even dramatic scenes where
they wouldn't even show up I mean that
Joe would come in you know spend ten
minutes behind the monitor and he'd look
and be like man you don't greatly bleed
where I'm doing a death scene of a major
character in the Marvel Universe and I
was kind of you know very much excited
to do it but a little also surprised
with you know all that that's riding on
these movies and they would just take
off and they'd be directing other things
and so you probably yeah I would say
that'd be the one of the biggest
surprises that I get to direct the death
scene of you know a Marvel character and
they were nowhere to be seen they were
always watching like they had a feed to
their you know their their to their
stage but they weren't there physically
yeah I heard about they were always
watching everything technology oh yeah
yeah they would whether it was you know
a hard line feed or somebody you know
when you go on is that with film the
monitor and and text it back to them or
you know or you know airdrop it or
whatever they were always just keeping
tabs on things which is great and you
want to you know I I respect that it's
there if they're filmed their process
and they're they want their vision to be
realized and I tried very hard to make
it so that you couldn't really tell
where were the Russos you know stopped
and where Sam Hargrove began so it was
one fluid movie going experience I
didn't want you know my might have my
own style but I didn't want to put that
into their movie
my job is second your director is just
or at the director and so I just wanted
to be you know their their vision you
think that extraction like infinity war
an endgame as you said must have been a
huge learning curve in terms of you know
that does are massive massive
productions
do you feel like extraction would have
been as good if you had made it before
infinity or do you think those two films
sort of really helped you as a director
with all that responsibility
I definitely think if I had made
extraction before working on Infinity
Ward in game a little bit a very
different movie and I think that the
experience I gather gained from those
two films and the responsibilities given
to me by the Russos and just even during
the process of making it the advice they
gave and the the things I learned
technically both working with actors and
all of those experiences stacked up to I
think you know propel me to the place
that I was ready ready when are you ever
ready to direct a movie really but the -
I was in a more prepared place to embark
on you know directing my own future I
definitely want to jump backwards - when
Netflix
I mean basically its extraction is an AG
bow booby that was I guess produced by
Netflix that the right way to say it
yeah it was it was Jo Jo wrote the
script and it was produced by AG bow and
that you know is their their movie and
they Netflix but was putting up the
money space basically so they they were
the producing partner and they were
super supportive and once we had hims
worth signed on once he showed interest
it was you know Netflix was very keen to
work with him and the work with the
Russos and Jo also had been he's very in
tune with the markets and with the way
that business is going and he'd been
saying you know for a couple years like
streaming he's just saying streaming
that's that you know that's the way of
the future is the streaming is where you
want to know want to be us we're gonna
consume our content so he's very much
wanted to work with Netflix and I think
it was you know a very great experience
for everybody one of the things that
listen I think that you action and
extraction is [ __ ] awesome
and I love how violent it is at times
and I'm just curious was was there any
pushback from Netflix or any sort of
guide in terms of how far you could go
with some of this action or is it sort
of like we trust you guys
you know we that was a great question
and a fun story we we went out we set
out to make a very real very violent
very visceral movie and it was one of
those things where they wasn't really
during the shooting process they very
much Netflix very much left us alone
they were always a phone call away to
support but there was nobody there
telling us how to we need to make movie
and then you know a lot of it because of
time and and what not a lot of the blood
and kind of the violence of some of
these things we were adding afterwards
in post because you know it just it's
crazy how I love the way squibs look in
certain things but then there's a
certain they're great for yes certain
things other things there's not quite as
real as I I want them to be and so we
would were in post it and they did there
were some passes early on where the
movie was much more violent than it is
now
and we they did have some some comments
there was a they caught it the blood
document and so they were they were
specific no so like you know might want
to dial this one back 80 percent might
want to dial this one back 20 you know
so we did them there was a
back-and-forth give and take and I think
to their credit that we we ended up
somewhere as they compromised this
somewhere we both everyone was
comfortable with what we were doing but
it was it was a fun process the back and
forth it was great
so the original title title I believe
was called daca and then it became
extraction and I wanted to know was it
ever gonna be called daca was that like
the template well you know it's one it's
funny maybe that was the script title
that was the working title I think we
all kind of we all liked the title it's
very unique but then once you started
seeing the reaction to the spoken word
daca
people go wait is that that Trump
immigration thing and you go no so it
automatically had a weird initial
connotation and so then the the second
bit was you look at it written in people
is it too hot like you know
most people don't know where that is on
a map like it's Dhaka Bangladesh is not
somewhere that in the Western world
people talk about everyday so it's not a
familiar term so we chose two strikes
against it as far as marketability is
concerned we all like the title because
you know it was the the town is kind of
a character in the movie or the city
sorry but you know we decided that it
was just it wasn't telling people enough
about the film and we just through
marketing and some test audiences and
whatnot we just we landed on a title
that was a little better for the
marketing strategies that Netflix had
planned sure watching the film one of
the things that I loved is how you were
filming on these real locations and with
all these people in the background and
you can tell some of them are just
watching the action like just standing
there
um how effing hard was it to make this
movie on location probably the biggest
hurdle we faced was the location
shooting of these big action sequences
because of the sheer number of people in
our as a my history as a stunt performer
and as a stunt coordinator just my
upbringing was safety-first like you're
doing these things but at the end of the
day everyone needs to go home to their
families and and be safe so that's
always the number one concern so when
you have a place as that crowded and
that popular we had times where when we
were shooting this we had two to three
hundred security personnel it posted up
in different doorways and streets just
because if we ran down a you know six to
ten city block run with these cars in a
car chase you know you've got men women
children dogs and cattle running around
that you know that's just their space
and so you know we make people aware but
then you don't want in the middle of a
car chase something someone or something
running out and in an accident happening
so we've that was one of those two
logistical hurdles that we faced and you
know hats off to the ad team for making
that happen because we did there was
never any problems we always had
everything locked up it was a very safe
shoot but yeah there were so many people
and like you said
and a lot of the people on the streets
when you're interacting with people or
vehicles those are placed there by us
and you know kind of in a again the ad
team and I'm observing how when we would
just pass through how people would just
stand and watch and so we're like you
know what would you do if the people
were fighting in the middle of the
street they're kind of just watch and it
was you know but then if you look up on
some of the shots if you you know we
some of you check out but but most
similar their leave you look up usually
in windows or on rooftops you can see
people watching and those weren't ours
those were people who were just just
watching you know enjoying the the live
show and you know some of them ended up
in the movie there is a shot of when
there's an action set piece where or
part of the set piece when Chris and the
kid are going through that building
being chased by the military and I saw
them go out into a thing and in the
background you can see all these people
standing there uh watch it and I'm like
oh those are just people living there
watching this thing being built hundred
percent hundred percent I was crazy
about that sequence is you know in
between takes you know then they were
all very respectful it was amazing they
it's not a place where a lot of action
films or any kind of films in that town
of Ahmedabad were made and they were
very enthralled with what was going on
but very respectful and it was insane
that because you know they were those
are the people you see in front of the
camera there's you know two other sides
you don't see if there are thousands of
people watching this and you know in
between takes when we do kinda we reset
and Chris would walk back down the
stairs out into this yellow you know
Coliseum the roar of the crowd the
applause was insane it was as if we're
at like a you know a European football
match like sir you got like the star
just goes out and his just waves his
hand and they would go crazy it was it
was the energy was so infectious that it
was they wanted to take all those people
with you to every location so they could
keep it they don't keep it fun uh yeah
how long was your first cut compared to
the finished film
um first cut trying to finish em well
there was an early cut of the film that
was about 2 hours and 15 something like
that oh no no was it that wasn't crazy
but because we always knew maybe shot a
lot of footage but we always knew that
it wanted to be about what it ended up
it was just a matter of you know the
first time you're putting it all all the
scenes in there because you just want to
see in all the scenes that are on the
page you shoot them and sometimes during
the course of production you'll be like
ah it doesn't work and you won't shoot
the scene but usually you shoot the
script and then you go back and just see
what's working in some of the scenes
even put it off so they're all in there
and it runs about you know about 220
little over 220 and you're like oh
that's long and we knew that and then
you just gotta get in there and do the
hard work of what you know scenes have
to go and there were quite a few scenes
that just whole scenes just had to get
lifted and you know removed and then we
truthfully went back once we had it all
kind of down and lean and mean and
telling the story we wanted to tell
there were a few places where you know
on the page you can make the the leap
from one moment you can fill in the
blanks a little easier when you're
reading for whatever reason they went
you know up on screen and some people
were confused by a few things so we
devised the you know a list of things we
needed to to go back and add to the
story to make it a little more you know
a little more cohesive for the
first-time viewer sure are there what
was the last thing that you cut out of
the film before you picture a locked and
why last thing forward picture locked
and wide there was a there was a version
of the scene in the a beautifully
written scene in English the scene where
if you're familiar with film where our
villain that kind of the father-son
relationship or or you know facsimile of
between our villain Tamara Seif and the
kid that was on the rooftop they have a
scene at a dining room table that you
know when the original cut was
ten minutes long and then we whittled it
down to you know maybe five and then it
was still is beautiful as this story the
Emir tells a story about this you know
this girlfriend used to have is very you
know metaphoric and a head like this is
fun
ring to it it just you know people
watched it most of the time they're just
a lot of the metaphors that kind of went
over their heads and we're like you know
do we need all of this let's just get to
the point until to give the advice and
so it you know a 10-minute original
scene ended up being I think it's like
maybe two minutes so we just really went
in there chop chop chop chop and then it
you know it says what it needs to say
and it's like kind of a nice moment the
most important thing in that scene was
the relationship and connection between
the two characters and what was said
although poetic you know didn't really
need it in the final product so we just
got to the meat of it got rid of the
rest so joe russo wrote the script and
i'm i'm just curious
he obviously has a lot of experience on
a lot of movies of TV how is it scripted
or some of these action set pieces is it
is it sort of like on the page is it
saying you know in massive car chase
ensues and then you're turning that into
that 12-minute crazy thing or you sorted
this out
ya know that Joe is great at describing
action his writing style is very tense
very terse very you know it keeps you
turning the page it's very entertaining
to read and he described he wrote the
the act just in the middle of the film
that we turned into this you know almost
12 minute one or that on the page what
was on the page was a sequence that when
you read it it was about a five to seven
minute read it but when you it read like
as big as any James Bond or Jason Bourne
chase and I was kind of like you know
this is this a an action in a designer's
dream but the we don't have those kind
of resources and the kind of the whole
point for me directing this thing is to
get to direct the action and the drama
so if I take this the biggest action
piece in the movie and give it to
somebody else it's not my action it's
not my you know my voice and so I was
like I like do this and looking at it
it's probably in my estimation when I
look at I'm just kind of you know from
the past experiences I've had probably
six to seven days a man unit in three
weeks of second unit it's a lot of time
you know to achieve what's on the page
and we just didn't have that we didn't
you know we had a shorter schedule and
we had to just make it work and so I was
like how do we how can we do all of that
where we can fit it in our schedule
tell all these different stories because
on the phase you followed you know
there's three different points to view
you had Chris and the kid and you had
the saju who played by Ron de puta who's
chasing them and then you had the police
so they have three different stories you
have to weave in and out and through
intercutting Joe did that and so I was
like I don't tell all these stories at
once and yet keep it with main unit and
do something different because I don't
want to do it you know my first movie I
want to a car chase and fun bunch of
fight stuff work one I'm not even
getting to shoot it - it's like we don't
have the money and resources to make it
as good as bond and Bourne week so we
you know he'll come out kind of like oh
they tried a good job so how do we make
it unique and then I was like now well
there's that I always mentioned the Joe
that I wanted to shoot it in kind of a
at least when we were in Dhaka there was
a differentiation between when we're
with the world of
you know V and the gangsters it's very
smooth that's their world it's very kind
of polished but then we go into Dhaka it
is it's like a documentary titled kind
of docudrama where you're it's just
things are happening real-time cameras a
little more just reactionary its
handheld it's just feel that an
unsteadiness of that environment and so
with that in mind I was like when we get
here what if we were to do now hear me
out an outfit if we do this as one shot
where we follow rake through the
extraction in real time so people get to
feel what it's like to go on this
journey with him and he's like yeah I
don't like it and I was like well let me
let me try to I'll try to ride it and
explain it to you like well we have to
make us and not be it was nothing about
you know like a stylistic versus ego or
whatever he just has to serve the story
he's like I don't want it just to be
some cool thing what's the point of it
and I was like well here's the point is
again to make people feel what they're
feeling and put him in at real time he's
like well we have to make sure we can
tell the story of rape and the kid saju
and the cops if you can figure that out
like I'll hear it out so I had to write
and design this thing and it was it was
tough you know because what you usually
find is with those sequences or like we
did with the town of gloms you're
sticking with one person it's one
person's point of view that you stay
with for the whole time and what I
wanted to try to do and experiment with
is leaving the hero at certain times and
go off with someone else's story main
street you know midstream you just and
so all of that was going to my mind how
do we make this interesting unique
fitting the time frame and a style that
is unique to the movie and you know that
that's what we came up with um my life I
think it's my last thing for you work
there's two last thing one I was
completely blown away by what Chad did
with John wick free and those dogs and
the stunts they pulled off when you
watch something like that when the
movies over you sort of just like shake
your head and say [ __ ] man I gotta raise
my game oh yeah I mean it was it was it
was actually a humorous time because we
were both posting our movies in the same
location at the same time he was a
little ahead of me and we were just
coming in
so he brought me in to see early cuts of
the movie and I remember watching it and
just just this sinking feeling in my
stomach of like yeah now he's he's still
the master
I am definitely still the student he's
like he is if the bar is so high with
him and the design of action and the
concepts on the world building I'm like
that's that's I don't know if that goal
is ever attainable what is the way I
look at them and the work they've done
he chats to house game day bleach but I
yes
stuff they're just I mean I leave to
cinema like I'm clapping during it like
I'm you know I'm smiling I'm afterwards
I'm calling them just being like guys
you guys have outdone yourselves you
know it's this is amazing and I love it
it's like if it's a mate for me it's a
friendly competitive environment because
you're not you know they're super
supportive like Chad came and watched an
early cut of my movie and gave me a lot
of amazing notes like these not we're
not out to you know take down the other
person or be like aha your movie sucked
or what we're excited about people doing
well because you know we're all in the
same game we come from the same world of
action people wanting to do action
movies and tell stories so it's very
supportive and yet there is a definite
hint of competition because yeah but
it's healthy because it does it pushes
me to try to think of better things and
I hopefully I can you know when I do
stuff it pushes them to think of bigger
and better things and I think the
ultimate there in the result is better
you know bigger better films for the
audiences so everybody wins
I mean I look at the competition between
the Beatles and The Beach Boys and they
each raise their game to pause these
amazing pieces of music to be composed
and you know I'm hoping that people look
at John with three or extraction and you
know they're like I got I mean this is
some I got to raise my game that would
be amazing I tell you what if anybody
else like you did uses John wick any Oh
John wicks and extraction in the same
sentence I will be you know on cloud
nine when I'm out
actually able to talk about the movie on
Twitter I am going to say quote unquote
extraction at times is Chris Hemsworth
John wit Lovett who I appreciate that
very much that's very high praise you
know what you're doing next or you sort
of like in that zone of let me see what
how extraction does we're kind of in the
zone yeah see you see how the movie
plays see how I respond to it and I'm
but I'm also I'm writing you know I got
my writing partner and I are adapting a
novel into it a script and we're you
know cuz I want to keep telling stories
and I'm constantly reading scripts my
team sends me stuff almost daily and I'm
reading digestive scripts just trying to
find the next story and in times like
these we're not quite sure when the next
job is gonna gonna happen who knows when
you know we'll be able to go about
business as usual it's just trying to
compile a bunch of possibilities and you
know build build up a compilation of
potentials that you can say hey once
once we go let's let's try to get these
things off the ground and have stories
that are gonna push me as a director and
hopefully entertain audiences around the
world in listen man I'm just gonna say I
know you got to go we're at the four
o'clock mark like we talked more than I
expected I just want to say sincerely
Congrats on the movie so happy to help
you promote it on Collider I wish you
nothing but the best thank you very much
I appreciate that